Are you
Hey
darling.
Happy.
Oh.
This afternoon we're going to talk about
the story of Jesus. It's actually a very
beautiful story and quite a sad story in
many senses as well.
This is a little map of where Jesus
spent most of his life. He spent some
time down in Egypt as a little boy.
as a baby. And most of the stories about
Jesus revolve around this area here of
cities like Korazim, Capernium,
Kaa, Betsa, all of these Nazareth.
That's the area where most of his
teaching took place. And as we go down
over here, of course, you come to
Bethlehem down there and Jerusalem. And
this is the great salt sea up there, the
Sea of Galilee.
The story of Jesus is a story that is a
story of someone who is a shepherd,
someone who leads his people. Now in my
country when I look at a shepherd it
doesn't make much sense because a
shepherd in my country drives sheep
ahead of him and they have dogs to her
the sheep to get them through a
particular gate and the dogs run and
they take them this side and they get to
them on that side and they funnel them
as it were and the sheep are actually a
little bit terrified during this whole
process. And so the idea of a shepherd
leading his sheep is something pretty
strange. But this is a typical Middle
Eastern picture where shepherds are
totally different where the shepherd
leads and the sheep follow. You can see
all these sheep are facing the shepherd
which is totally different to what is
the case in other countries. Here's a
typical shepherd scene in uh the Middle
East where you have your shepherd and
his little flock of sheep around him.
And again, they're all facing him. Isn't
that cute? I like that. And uh this man
had such a nice rugged face, I had to
photograph him.
Here we took a little video of a typical
shepherd scene. Again, the sheep are
there, the shepherds over there, and
they trust their shepherd. And let's
watch this.
>> He walks. The sheep walk. They don't let
him get away.
They're very attached to their shepherd.
That's a beautiful picture of how Jesus
depicts himself as a shepherd. He leads
out and we follow. The story of Jesus is
the most amazing story that has ever
transpired in the universe. And
everywhere, unfortunately, everywhere
where you go in the Middle East, they
will have made a holy site out of all
these places. And people believe that
there is some sanctity in going to these
holy sites. It's nice to to be there and
it's nice to see them, but uh there is
no sanctity in a place. You can meet
Jesus as effectively in your little room
as you can over here. Of course, if you
want to expand your knowledge and see
what it was like in those areas, then
that's a different story. But to go
there to get a special grace, that is a
deception. So, this is apparently the
cave where the shepherds were that
evening. And you can see they have a
star there on the floor as they were
informed of the birth of Jesus. And in
this cave they have put down a church
with the reliefs on the side of the
shepherd boys in the in the environment
when the angel came to tell them that
Jesus had been born in Bethlehem.
They must have been out in a field like
this. So the time of year when this
happened could not have been the 25th of
December which happens to be the
birthday of all the pagan main deities
like Osiris and Zeus and all of them
because the shepherds were out in the
field. That means it must have been in a
temperate time and not in the middle of
winter as the 25th of December would
depict. This over here is the field of
Ruth. That's a nice story. The story of
Ruth the Moabitete, which is another
story in the Bible which tells us that
God does not reject nations. Even though
Moab was a apostate nation, someone out
of Moab accepted Jesus as their personal
savior. They didn't know him as such
because he wasn't born yet. But they
believed that the God of the Israelites
was the true God and was to be their God
as well. This is the city of Bethlehem
where Jesus was born
and some beautiful sightes there. Who's
been there?
Ah, great. Some beautiful sites. The
people there are magnificent to watch.
It's like being transported back into
the Middle Ages in a sense. And uh this
old man over here, he's very impressive.
There are lots of these rugged faces
around. And as you walk these streets,
it's really fascinating. I was there
quite a few times. It's quite a
dangerous area to be around in. In case
in fact, in one instance, we were stoned
and uh managed to survive that one. In
other instances, we were the only ones
that were traveling backwards and
forwards between the Israeli side and
the Lebanese side. Fascinating stories.
The Israelis come and they put up a a
fence. They just put it up and everybody
this side stays that side, everybody
that side stays that side. But they
happen to put this fence right through
this man's property.
And this was our tour guide. And so he
was the only tour guide who had a
license to be on both sides. That was
quite interesting. So we were the only
ones who were allowed onto both sides.
Everybody else had to stay on their
side. I think that's divine providence.
I think the Lord helped us there. And it
was terrific because you could go into
places nobody could go because
everything was sealed off. We had the
place to ourselves. I've been to
Bethlehem and other places when you
cannot move for all the tourists. I mean
there are hundreds of tourists in these
churches. You stand in queues forever.
We had the church all to ourselves
totally empty. We could go to all these
sites. It was marvelous. And the tour
guides, they were desperate for money.
So they would sneak you into places
you'd never normally go to. That was
very nice. So something good can come
out of something bad. typical scenes of
the marketplace. This is a butcher if
you would like to purchase your meat.
There it hangs. And uh there's a
tremendous buzz around
as you go and purchase your meat. So I'm
not so sure whether that's a good idea.
This man over here tried to sell me this
chicken and he was adamant that I had to
buy this chicken. It was on the hoof. It
was alive.
And uh he wouldn't let me go. I told him
I'm not interested in buying his
chicken, but he wouldn't let me go. So,
he haggled with me and he wouldn't let
me. He ran after me. He insisted I buy
that chicken.
Eventually, it drove me nuts. So, I
said, "Okay, I'll bargain with him for
his chicken."
And so, I bargained him down and down
and down and down and down and down for
his chicken until he got angry with me,
which was very good. And I bargained
more and I bargained more and eventually
he got angry and he says that you can
have it for nothing.
And I told him I'm a vegetarian.
That was the look on his face. Total
incredul. He didn't believe that
something like this was possible. But
then he laughed afterwards and we made
good friends. This is a typical bakery
there. And uh I must say it doesn't look
too hot, does it?
>> No. You know. Well, anyway, bread is
bread and baked in the oven. It's
probably fine. And uh women weren't
allowed in here because that's not fit
for a woman. A place like that where you
bake bread. Try and tell that to Bljanka
at the back there. I don't think she
would agree. And uh nevertheless, this
is the famous church of the nativity
where Jesus was born or so they say. We
never know whether these holy sites are
these sites. Some of them probably are
pretty accurate and that this could
represent the place where Jesus was
born. And these of course these sites
were chosen very early on in the
history. and this particular one by
Constantine's mother and she found that
this was the site and so they built this
church which was of course a Bzantine
church which means it was Orthodox
and so there's been a tremendous war in
this area between the Orthodox and the
Catholics who claim these sites for
themselves. This war was not resolved
until the ecumenical movement come came
along. And so this church now is shared
by the Orthodox Church and the Roman
Catholic Church. And they alternate the
masses in there.
Now when you come into this place, you
have to enter a little door that's very
low. So you have to bend down and that
is to show a sign of respect and
humility. So you have to crawl through
it as it were. And as you see, the
church was totally empty when we were
there. Not a cell there. When I was
there the previous time, it was packed.
And the floor is actually a false floor.
And the real floor is underneath and
still has the original mosaic from
Constantine's time. So this is a very
ancient church. And of course being a
holy place, it is filled with
mythologies and histories that probably
never took place. But it was interesting
to me the sunbeam that came in to this
church while I was there. And they're up
against the one pillar. You have these
holes over here. Can you see them? And
what are these holes? Well, the legend
goes that Mary appeared in the church
one day and then she took her fingers
and made them in the shape of a cross
like this and she went up against the
pillow and went
and there were the holes. There they
were. Those are Mary's fingers that made
the holes. And if you put your fingers
into the holes, they say you receive a
special blessing. Now, as I looked at
those holes, I saw that the edges were
pretty much chipped and what have you. I
think it was a very poor drill job that
they did over there. If it really was
divine, they would have been burnt in
there very neatly. So this is a type of
story that attracts the people and you
will be amazed how in normal times they
line up in long cues and put their
fingers in there and really believe that
they will receive a special blessing
from Mary if they put their fingers into
them.
Now the church of course previously had
been lower. I showed you that the lower
floor that was covered by the boards was
considerably lower than the present
floor. So if you want to go down to the
original place where they claim the crib
of Jesus stood, you have to go down
these steps and you enter into the
seleure. And there it is. And this is
where apparently the crib stood on that
very spot over there. So if you put your
hand over there, you can get this day is
still an absolution from the Roman
Catholic Church. That means all your
sins are forgiven by just going poop
touching that spot. And in fact, in some
of these spots, you can have your sins
forgiven 90 days in advance.
So if you're planning the mother of all
parties, it's good to go and put your
hand there, you know, and for three
months you can just hang loose. That's
pretty neat. and no questions asked, no
penalties forthcoming from heaven.
Now, we were there at a time when there
was no one there, which was surprising.
So, when we actually did arrive there,
there's nobody should have been there.
These people were very very surprised.
They were busy with their normal rituals
and uh we sort of interrupted this
ritual which did not particularly please
them. But uh we had a camera there and I
took pictures with my camera. Should
have seen the looks. I'll show you one
just now that we got. And this is now an
Orthodox mass in the basement in the
cellar of this church where normally one
should not be.
Here they are. This is how they were
dressed in black hoods. They look more
like members of the Klux Clan than they
do like monks. These are Orthodox monks
saying a particular mass.
And uh here is sort of what transpired.
Is there a sound?
Man's very angry with us for
photographing.
Now that man over there, I think if
looks could kill, I would have been
gone.
He doesn't look too friendly. Huh?
So, this is the type of ritual that goes
on. I don't know what type of mass that
was, but uh interesting nevertheless.
And then when the Orthodox people leave,
then the Roman Catholics come in and
they do their thing. Here is a group of
pilgrims on a in a Roman Catholic
setting. There's one lady over there.
She's got three crosses in front of her
and her face is covered. And it's a good
place, they say, to come if you want to
be totally cleansed of whatever your
problem is. Outside this church they
have Uranomous's statue writing over
there scriptures. They have the skull
down there. This is also occult of
course the question of death and life
and cycles of death and life. And going
down down into the basement of the
church we find this cave. Now apparently
this is the cave so they say where Mary
actually gave birth. But you'll also
notice the triple arches which are
typical of paganism.
And so whether this is so or whether
this was a pagan site, I cannot tell.
Also in the basement of this church, you
will find the skulls of what they say
are the skulls of the babies that Herod
had killed. I don't particularly believe
that either, but uh that is what they
say. And down there, that's one of them
them that I photographed down there. And
one occasion while while I was there, a
bomb exploded in a place where I'd just
been few seconds previously.
So quite a dangerous place. Here's
another cave. And in this cave, there's
also a Marian shrine. And they claim
that this is where Mary nursed her
infant. Why the places should be
different? I don't know. the one who is
she was born and they even have the cave
where Joseph waited while Mary was given
giving birth in the other room. So very
interesting when you come to this one
this is called the milk shrine
and uh when you enter that it's called
milk grotto like grotto doule and inside
you go it's another cave church built
into a cave another pagan symbol over
there and up against the walls you have
these white splotches
and these are certified by Rome with
certification from from the papacy that
that is the milk of Mary that squirted
against the walls when she yes this is
serious stuff when she was nursing
Jesus.
So the guide who was there was very
excited about showing us this and you
can receive special uncction. There's
the certificate of approval from the
Vatican saying that these are genuine
milk splotches of Mary. So I said to the
guide, you know, I've been in the other
caves as well and there are similar
white splotches against the walls. These
are calcium carbonate deposits from
rain. He says, "Yes, and the other
caves, but not this one. This is milk.
This is milk. This is the famous milk
grotto." And if you go down, they have
all these little subcaves.
And there you can see this typical icon
in one of them. Now this is actually
paganism. This is the Isis legend. You
see in the Isis legend, Mary Mary takes
the place of Isis. And Isis was also the
queen of fertility. After all, she
managed to bear Horus while her husband
was dead by reconstructing him. And so
if people had fertility problems, they
would particularly pray to Isis and that
would solve their fertility problems, if
they had nursing problems, then they
would pray to Isis and then the milk
would flow. This is ancient paganism
resurrected in modern Christianity in
these places.
Jesus of course survived the slaughter
of Herod and the family went down to
Egypt. So the Bible tells us and they
spent some time in Egypt and then in
time again for the boy to obtain his
manhood as it is the custom in Israel
returned from Egypt and they lived in
Nazareth. That's what the Bible tells
us. Now, if we go down to Egypt, this is
the very spot where apparently the Holy
Family came and they have these icons
down there. Again, the Orthodox church
in these places has these particular
so-called holy sites. And this is the
story of Joseph and his family coming
down to Egypt. And one of the most
famous churches there is the Coptic
Orthodox Patriarchy Monastery and Virgin
Mary Church in Adawa in Egypt. There's a
very very famous church and just a few
years ago, I forget exactly how many
years ago, but in the late 90s somewhere
Mary appeared in this there were
apparitions of Mary in this place and
the Muslim world went totally ballistic.
Of course, it couldn't have been Mary
because that's not biblical, but
nevertheless, apparitions took place
over here in this patriarch.
And uh here you can see some of the
icons in that church, some of the
symbolism. And it just happened to be
Palm Sunday when we were there. So the
patriarch over here was carrying um
things made of palm leaves.
Here's also the story in this church,
the flight of the Holy Family to Egypt
of how they moved down uh from where
they were down to Egypt. And they have
the story of how they came down with the
river Nile and stayed in this particular
place. And it's fascinating that this
church also has the miracle book sort of
copying what happened. This book, this
very heavy book came floating down the
Nile one day and uh being a holy site,
the people here really are fervent to
receive these blessings. This is the
book that came floating down the Nile
and it was open on a particular page
also. Very interesting. That is it. A
closer look at that. And there's a
little plaque of what happened and on
which pages was open. Now, it's a
metalbound book, but it didn't sink. It
floated. You know, like the axe, so they
say. And it says, "The floating Bible."
On Friday, 12th March 1976, after the
morning liturgy, the people noticed an
object floating on the water near the
steps where the Holy Family had
embarked. Some members of the church
came down and found it was a Bible
floating on the water open at Isaiah
19:25.
Blessed be Egypt, my people. Despite the
inundation of the water and the
heaviness of the book, it was still
afloat. And this was considered a
miracle by the people, a sign of God as
a special blessing towards them. That's
a fascinating text that they quote
there. Isaiah 19:25. Of course, it
doesn't say only that. It's a a text
that talks about the end times and says,
"Blessed is there will be a blessing in
Egypt and in Assyria and in Jerusalem."
meaning that God's people's message will
have reached even the heathen nations
and many will accept the righteousness
of Christ. Sort of a a nice prophecy
about end time fulfillments. So they
just took up that little piece and
popped it in there to make it seem as if
they were the real people. Which is
actually what the Quran also does saying
that Ishmael is the true heir and not
Jacob.
This is the place where this Bible came
floating down the river. Now while we
are in Egypt, I just want to show you
one place that I found very fascinating.
It's a place called the dump city. This
is the most horrendous place I've ever
seen in my entire life. As you come
through the streets of Cairo, now Cairo
has about 50 million people living in
Cairo and surrounds. It is the most
chaotic city on the face of the planet.
There is nothing like it. It's
Armageddon waiting to happen. But can
you imagine the dump and the filth and
the garbage of that city? Now in normal
cities, what do you do with garbage?
You take it out and you put it onto
dumps somewhere outside the city or you
incinerate it or you do whatever. Can
you imagine 50 million people living in
an environment like that? And they take
their dump, their garbage, and they take
it to the poor area and they dump it in
the street. And these poor people sift
through all the garbage and they live
amongst the garbage. This is literally a
city of rubbish within a city. If you
take pictures, they get very angry. So,
my pictures are not very good. They're
sort of taken like this, you know, sort
of
like that. They would they would
literally kill you if they saw you take
a picture. But what's amazing about this
city is that as you come through the
dump city, there's a portal. And this is
the portal. And when you come through
it, you're suddenly in a totally
different world. I'll show you what it
looks like. It's amazing. This is when
you come into the dump city. And this is
how the people live over there. One
cannot imagine it. My heart really went
out to them. This is what it looks like.
Whole rooms full of just garbage. And
they live in there. This is their these
are their houses.
And uh all of these rooms, all of the
buildings, everything is garbage. And
here you can see the dump trucks coming
in by their hundreds. The traffic jams
are unbelievable. Now, every street
looks like this. This is just one
street. These are all the dump trucks
coming in offloading their garbage. The
stench is unbelievable
for for us just to travel through. We
didn't even touch anything. I got trench
mouth and the whole rest of our team had
diarrhea after just going through there.
That's it. It is unbelievable. The germs
in there are killer bugs. And these
people must have an immune system second
to none.
Here you can see the traffic jams and
the garbage and the filth lying all
over. The pictures are not very good.
They're shaky. Here comes a donkey
bearing a load of rubbish to be dumped
in the city. There it is. A whole pile
of rubbish. This man is having his tea
next to his rubbish dump. Can you see
that? Where he's sort this is rubbish he
has sorted. Probably his only value in
life. and these little kids living and
walking amongst rubbish. Can you believe
that? It is horrendous. I just want to
grab this little kid and put her in a in
a nice clean safe environment. It is
shocking. The stores. There lies the
rubbish. Here is the store. And as you
come through that portal, suddenly
you're in a different world. It's just
it's just like that. It's beautifully
clean. And there stands this little
Orthodox church and hune rock all
around. And all of this is heuned out of
solid rock. It's unbelievable this
little Orthodox church. There it is.
It's the church of St. Bola.
And you can see it is absolutely
amazing. Over here there's an
amphitheater. And one man, one man, one
Orthodox Polish man spent his life here.
A young man, young man went here and he
sculpted the entire little city. And
there's the amphitheater that he dug out
probably with some help from the
environment. And that's him. That's the
man. He did all the work that you will
see. Unbelievable. And the entire walls
of this rock city are chiseled out with
the story of Jesus. in the middle of a
Muslim world. You come through a city of
dump and rubbish and garbage and you're
in this beautifully clean place with
this little chapel and the story of
Jesus written over the walls. Jesus uh
with the shepherd's boys over here at
the time of his birth depicted over
there. The story of his birth. All of
this chiseled into solid rock. I am the
good shepherd chiseled out of solid
rock. The stories of the Bible, the
walking on the water and uh the woman at
the well for example.
And these are huge sculptures just to
give you an idea. This is a sheer face
rock face with uh some chiseled material
on it. Any large boulder has been
transformed into a work of art of Jesus.
This is the story of Lazarus coming out
of his tomb. That's the story of Jesus
coming out of his tomb. And one of you
can just get the size here. This is the
sheer rock face where he's been working.
And he chiseled all of this. And there
you have the tremendous story of
Jesus. Let's get closer. Uh while he was
blessing them, he ascended into heaven.
And the next one is uh we'll see the son
of man coming in the clouds with great
power and glory. One man having
transformed the area into an area of
hope. I was very impressed. And that's
more or less what the world is like. You
come through this world which is
represented by the city of dumps. And as
you come through, the only hope that you
can have to make it to the other side is
the story of Jesus. I will see the son
of man come with the clouds with great
power and glory and there will be no
more city of dumps.
The story of Jesus is probably
the most heart-rening story that has
ever been told. I know many films have
been made and even this latest film that
has been made cannot even touch on what
happened to Jesus and what his life must
have been like when they came back to
Jerusalem. Well, Jerusalem today is a
totally different city. It's a city of
pilgrimages. People in their thousands
undergo pilgrimages. Here you have a
group of nuns leading a pilgrimage
behind the cross. And people are filled
with a kind of euphoria. They've been to
this place. They've experienced it. But
if a place takes the place of Jesus,
then we have a problem. This is the
wailing wall. And uh there you have the
famous Dome of the Rock in the
background. This whailing wall is not
part of the original temple. It's part
of the outer court of the temple here up
the stairs. You can go into this area.
Today you're not allowed in there
anymore. They stopped us over here. So I
took this picture just through the
crack. That's a replica of what the
temple looked like. And here's a huge
column that was to be part of that
temple. So that gives us an idea of the
size of the original temple. This one
was never used because it had a crack in
it.
And that is probably a normals size
replica of the manora. This is one that
they have made in case they restore uh
the temple site. These are the Jews at
their whailing wall. And you notice all
these little letters stuck into the wall
over here. People come here, they write
their little letters of whatever their
dreams in life are, and they stick them
in there. Here's a little short video.
Now, when I looked at all of these very
orthodox, very sincere Jews standing in
front of that wall, showing their
reverence towards a wall. I wondered to
myself, if they only knew the rock of
their salvation, if they could only
understand that there is no salvation in
a in a brick wall, the only salvation is
in the one that it represented.
People today tend to make holy sites out
of places. Isn't that sad? And then they
miss the one that it is supposed to
represent. Underneath the wall, there's
a tunnel
and it's called the secret passage.
And as you go through it, you can also
come into the back of this place. And
you can see where the highly orthodox
Jews and rabbis come together. Now,
normally these people will just ignore
you. But times have changed. I was
stunned. Normally, if you as a as a
pagan come into this place, they will
detest you. They will give you a filthy
look. What is this unclean fellow doing
in such a holy sight? I was stunned this
time when I was there. As I went into
this place, it was just a few months
ago, most of these rabbis would come and
beg for money, something they would
never have done even two, three years
ago. Things must be really tough in that
place for them to do that. But this is
their holiest site here where you have
these remnants of the ancient wall. And
just above on the other side stands the
Dome of the Rock. Here's an Orthodox uh
rabbi uh going through his ritual.
Notice that he has uh the commandments
on his forehead, the law, the Torah, and
he has them on his hand because the
Bible said you must bind them on your
forehead and bind them on your hand. Do
you think that's what God had in mind
that you make a replica and put it over
there and then the job's done? Or do you
think God had in mind that you must
think accordingly and act accordingly?
Doesn't that make more sense? I think
that makes more sense. Here's a typical
stone from that ancient temple site.
This was a Herod stone. If it had these
this recess, then you know that it was a
stone from the original temple. So when
they reused the stones of the temple,
they built them into all kinds of
structures and walls. So this must have
been an original temple stone of the
temple today in another wall. This is
the um grave of David. And just like in
Catholic sites, the Jews will come over
here. This is the baptismal site of
Jesus. And this is actually where the
story starts. The story tells us that
when Jesus was baptized, the voice of
God was heard saying, "This is my
beloved son in whom I am well pleased."
And from there the Bible tells us that
Jesus was taken into the wilderness to
be tempted. And Matthew 4:2 says, "And
when he had fasted 40 days and 40
nights, he was afterwards hungry."
"If you are the son of God, command that
these stones be made bread,"
said the devil. Now, it's an interesting
statement. if you are the son of God. So
first he questions
God's validity, God's word and God's son
as to his genuiness.
And then he challenges him to command
the stones to be made bread. And Jesus
answers, "It is written, man shall not
live by bread alone, but by every word
that proceeds out of the mouth of God."
Of course, you need a King James version
to read that if you don't have the King
James version. Uh you will have to stop
over there because the rest won't be in
your Bibles. But nevertheless, that's
another story. Man shall not live by
bread alone, but by every word that
proceeds out of the mouth of God. Now,
we think that the temptations weren't
tremendous temptations, but they really
were because in these temptations, Jesus
met every condition of fallen man. Every
condition. The first thing that Adam and
Eve had done is they had partaken of the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
In other words, appetite. It was good
for food was one of their first
problems. Here Jesus conquered after
fasting 40 days and 40 nights where Adam
and Eve failed in all the splendor and
luxury that they had conquering appetite
and conquering doubts.
If you are the son of God, did God
really say that? So here Jesus conquers
the sin of doubt and he conquers the sin
of human appetite and passion all in
one. And the temptation must have been
much worse than it was for Adam and Eve.
This is today the highest sight of the
ancient wall and uh we don't have the
temple which must have stood over there
somewhere. So originally the devil must
have taken him to this wall somewhere
over here where the temple stood and
threatened to throw him down. Let's go
to this site over here. That's that
spot. That gives you an idea of the
height. And the second temptation is if
you are the son of God, again the same
question.
Cast yourself down. For it is written,
he shall give his angels charge
concerning you. in their hands they
shall bear you up, lest at any time you
dash your foot against a stone.
And Jesus answers again and says, "It is
written again, you shall not tempt the
Lord your God." This is the second
great temptation of mankind.
And it is a sad fact. If we let listen
to the lectures that we did yesterday,
then this is the sin that most of
mankind is succumbing to. It's the sin
of presumption. The sin of presumption.
Imagine two people trying to solve a
crisis on the other side of the road.
Whatever it is, a child in trouble or
whatever. The one runs across the road
saying, "I am the child of God. God will
protect me." And he runs across the
road. Another one comes and says, "God,
there is a crisis on the other side.
Help me across this road." and he runs
across the road. The two to the outside
observer are absolutely identical. But
the one is presumption and the other one
is faith. Can you see how close they are
together? That's how close they are
together. And the modern Christianity
most of the movements today are
practicing presumption power religion.
Whereas faith is something totally
different. And Jesus could have thrown
himself down because this is what it
says in the Bible. But it is written,
"You shall not be presumptuous." The
third one, the devil took him up on a
very high mountain and showed him all
the kingdoms of the world and their
glory. And he said to him, "All these
things I will give you if you will fall
down and worship me." Now people say,
"Now surely Jesus knew that he was God
and that he was going to win. In any
case, why should he do this?"
But this was not only the question that
was being asked over here. The devil had
him alone and Satan in all his glory
said, "I will surrender it all to you
again without you having to die if you
will just once bow down."
And of course, the sin to be overcome
here is the sin of the love of the
world. And I believe most people will be
lost because of this very particular
temptation. Go Satan, for it is written,
you shall worship the Lord your God and
him only shall you serve. Love of the
world will not get us anywhere. So in
these three temptations, Jesus basically
conquers on behalf of man the major
temptations which we all have to face in
one form or another. And then of course
he departed to the Sea of Galilee.
And uh on the way there there is this
quaint little town. It's called Ma
Alula. And this is the only little town
left in the whole world where the
language that is spoken is Aramaic. Now
this is the language that Jesus spoke.
And uh so it's nice to go there. It's a
nice neat little place. And it's also an
Orthodox place largely and Orthodox and
Muslim. And they speak Aramaic. And the
little kids speak only Aramaic. They're
very, very strict in their Aramaic. So,
it's nice to hear what it sounds like.
Here is one of these Orthodox priests
doing service in that particular place.
And uh we went to him and asked him
whether he wouldn't pray the Lord's
prayer for us in Aramaic so that we
could hear what the language of Jesus
was like. And uh I'll share that with
you.
Amen. That was the our father in
Aramaic. The Sea of Galilee,
an amazing place. This is the uh
supposedly one of the sites. There's
more than one site, but this is one of
the site where the wedding to Kaa
apparently took place. And you can see
the jars over there. That's what the
original jars actually looked like. And
like this, those were the rough stone
jars that they first poured it in. Then
they kept it in these jars of clay. And
this over here is the city of Jesus.
This is where Jesus actually performed
most of his work and did most of his
preaching, the city of Capernium. And
I'll take you in there in the next
session.
Let us go to the city of Capernium
which is known as the town of Jesus.
This over here is a very famous site.
Now if you look at it, it looks like
nothing but actually on top of it
there's a huge building built right over
it. There you can see the concrete
pillars and the some of the concrete
floor. What is this? This is the house
of Peter.
This was the house of Peter. Peter lived
here and that was his home. And Jesus
must have spent many times in that town
in that house. Whether it is the house
of Peter, no one really knows. But the
Roman Catholic Church claims that this
is the house of Peter. And if you want
to see what's built above it, there it
is. A huge concrete structure standing
on pillars over the house of Peter.
And it says there
uh Blato Petro Aposto. This is the place
where Peter stayed. And Peter, of
course, means pebble, little rock. And
Rome has built its church on this Peter.
And there they have a statue of Peter
right outside of it with a fish next to
him. And this giant statue of Peter,
enormous.
This is a fascinating story because
Simon was also the name of of course
Simon Magus and Simon Magus according to
Alifas Levi was the one who became the
Petra the ptr the Peter on which of
course today we would base this whole
system because this Simon Magus became
sorcerer to Nero. He was, in other
words, the high priest, if you were, of
the Roman Caesars. So whether the Peter
that they're honoring over here is the
apostle is really doubtful. It's
probably Simon Magus, the magician, the
sorcerer, the occultist that was being
honored. But the church built this huge
edifice over the house of Peter.
And uh at the foot of the statue, you
can see the symbols of the fish and all
of these. And it tells us that this is
Peter the Apostle. And a little bit
further away there is the synagogue. So
here's this huge building out of
concrete with this huge statue of Peter.
Just a little away across the road is
the remnant of the synagogue, probably
the synagogue where Jesus taught the
most. And there's a little rusted plaque
which says the late century AD white
synagogue, synagogue of Jesus.
You know, now if I really was going to
build one huge Christian edifice,
wouldn't I build it there where Jesus
spent most of his time? Why build it
over a little house that's possibly the
house of Peter? Whether it is or not,
he's not unsure. It could be because
from the Bible description, it says when
they came out of the synagogue, they
went across to the house of Peter. And
that house is right across. So, it's
possible, but it could also be the one
next door. Who knows? But it's possible.
Now this is the synagogue where Jesus
actually taught. Here's another little
town. So Capernium was the one town. The
other one is Korazim.
And this is what's left of Korazim. Not
very much. Some ruins are left over
there. These are the cities that Jesus
cursed. And Jesus said, "If the miracles
that had been done in you had been done
in Sidon or Sodom and Gomorrah, they
would have accepted the message. But you
had ample opportunity." Jesus walked
through those cities and not one person
remained sick in those cities and they
accepted him not. Here's another famous
holy place. This is the holy place of
the biatitudes.
When you go in there, you better be
properly dressed. This is the church of
the biatitudes, a very famous site. And
uh Pope John Paul 2 has been there, of
course, twice. And uh this is the
conclave. And this is the field. This is
probably the field where Jesus spoke his
very first sermon. This is a very
impressive sermon.
It's the most intricate,
most sublime sermon that has ever been
preached to mankind. And most people
today misquote this sermon to such a
terrible extent. The biatitudes Matthew
53-10.
Jesus starts off by saying, "Blessed are
the poor." And the word for blessed
there is macarios, which means a
heavenly blessing. A blessing that can
only come from a divine source. Such an
enormous blessing. And the word used for
poor there is the Greek tocos which
means abject poverty.
Nothing but abject abject poverty. Not
one might to rupt together. And he
starts off his sermon, the Jews sitting
there in their thousands waiting for him
to announce himself as the Messiah and
to say, "I am the Messiah. You are the
chosen people of God. I have come to set
you free from the Roman yoke. You will
rise and be the greatest in heaven."
That's what they're waiting for. And
here he gets up and the first words as
Messiah that he speaks are
blessed are the poor. And there are
various words for poor in the Greek. And
he uses the one which describes abject
poverty instead of greatness and
richness and and uh wonder and whatever
adjective you'd like to apply to them.
They are to be poor in spirit for theirs
is the kingdom of heaven. And his second
beatitude was blessed are they that
mourn. They wanted to rejoice. They
didn't want to mourn.
And again the mourning there there are
different levels of mourning in the
Greek. And the Greek word there is
pentio which means
abject sorrow. The sorrow that you could
have for the loss of an only child,
that type of sorrow.
Blessed are they that mourn, for they
shall be comforted.
Blessed are the meek, for they shall
inherit the earth. This is a meekness
that uh is a humility that you cannot
describe in human words practically. And
blessed are they which do hunger and
thirst after righteousness, for they
shall be filled. And again, the word
hunger there is a hunger pang that you
would feel after you've been roaming
around for days and days in a desert
without food or water. That type of
hunger and that type of thirst. What was
Jesus doing there?
Was he trying to destroy their demeanor?
Was he trying to say something else to
what they expected? He certainly was. In
fact, what Jesus is doing here, he is
displaying the Christian walk. That's
what he's explaining.
And he's saying, "Blessed are the poor
in spirit, for theirs is the kingdom of
heaven." In other words, those who
realize their bankruptcy,
those who realize that they have nothing
to offer. I come to Jesus with nothing
to offer. I cannot say to him, "Lord, I
have one might here. Can I purchase my
way to heaven? I've got nothing. I am
absolutely
poverty struck. I have nothing to offer
but a sinstained life. That's it. So, I
must come to the point where I realize
that I'm poor, that I have nothing to
offer." And then the very next step is
blessed are they that mourn for they
shall be comforted.
I must not only realize that I have
nothing to offer as a sinstained
individual. I must experience sorrow for
what? For sin. I must experience my
sorrow for sin. And I must look at the
son of God and I must feel sorrow. And I
must have repentance.
And I must say, Lord, forgive me. I'm
sorry for what I have done. Genuine
repentance is the next step in the
Christian walk. Blessed are the meek.
Once you have realized that you are
bankrupt, once you have realized that
you are responsible for the death of the
son of God, once you have experienced
real sorrow, there's no more time to
ride around on your high horse thinking
that you are better than everyone else.
Time to climb down and to experience
humility and to know that others and God
are greater than you.
It's a very difficult road for mankind
to travel. It's contrary to every human
emotion.
Blessed are they which do hunger and
thirst after righteousness, for they
shall be full. Your Christian walk
doesn't end with realizing you're a
sinner, sorrow for sin, and becoming
more humble about yourself. It has to
continue in a process known as
sanctification
which means Lord change my vile
character. Paul says I must crucify the
old man every single day and I must ask
God to change me and I have a perfect
pattern which is Jesus Christ and I must
say Lord change me into that image that
I may truly reflect me. I long to be
more like you and less like me because
really I am pretty pathetic. That's the
Christian walk. What's the next step?
Once you have done this, then you can be
merciful for they shall obtain mercy.
You see, we tend to believe we are
better than others and then we become
judgmental. One of the biggest problems
in a church is being judgmental, isn't
it? Now, did you know so and so still
does this and that and the other? And
you know that kid over there, I mean,
he's on drugs. I mean, wow, what do you
expect? The parents are, you know, this,
that, and the other. Instead of feeding
the hunger and looking at your own self
and saying, well, look at yourself. What
a miserable sod you are. Do you think
they are any worse than you are? Why can
you not have mercy and sympathy on them?
because God had sympathy and mercy
towards you.
>> Isn't that what it's about? So Jesus
says once you have come along this road,
once you have experienced repentance and
once you have sorrowed for your sin and
once you've climbed down from your high
horse and once you ask the Lord to
change you, that will make you merciful
and you will have pity on those that
have not had the advantage of this
insight. Blessed be the merciful
and then blessed are the pure in heart
for they shall see God. I remember when
I came into this church I came in from
the world. I was a hard worldling in a
very cutthroat business. University is
very cutthroat and you work your way
through the top. And my mind was a
sewer.
And I said to God, you know, I don't
want to have a mind like this anymore.
And God will help one to clean up the
act and to develop nice thoughts where
evil thoughts abound. This is the
process of sanctification.
Christianity doesn't stop with knowing
Jesus.
It's no good to know Jesus. You won't be
saved by just knowing Jesus. Doesn't the
devil know Jesus? Is he saved because he
knows Jesus? No. We have to allow God to
change us to clean up our act. Blessed
are the peacemakers, for they shall be
called children of God. You see, only
once you've gone through the whole
series of growth aspects do you come to
the peacemakers. What is a peacemaker? A
peacemaker is someone who realizes the
peace of God in his heart. Great peace
have they who love thy law, says Psalms
119.
This is a peace which is a heavenly
peace. It always amazes me when
politicians take that particular bi
biatitude, apply it to themselves and
give themselves huge awards without
having gone through any of the previous
steps in the Christian experience.
That's not a peacemaker. A peacemaker is
someone who has made peace with God.
That's a peacemaker. That's a
peacemaker.
And blessed are they which are
persecuted. Isn't that amazing? for
righteousness sake for theirs is the
kingdom of God. What's the very last
thing that that the Lord mentions here?
What's the last beatitude?
Blessed are they which are persecuted.
In other words, if you go through this
process, if you feel sorrow for sin, if
you ask for forgiveness, if you allow
the Lord to change your heart, if you
are willing to climb down from your high
horse, if you want the peace of God in
your heart, you will be an irritation to
the world and they will persecute you.
It's guaranteed.
And that's the process of the Christian
walk. totally the opposite of what
mankind in this world wants today. And
the lessons that Jesus taught on the Sea
of Galilee are absolutely
the most fundamental lessons that
mankind needs. We need to take our Bible
and we need to be aware. If you have a
Bible that's marked in red where Jesus
speaks, you need to be aware. I must
read this care. We read them like
stories. We must read this carefully
because this is God speaking directly to
us. Every word is a talent of gold.
Every word, even the butts and the this
will be in the right places for
particular reasons. So we need to pay
attention what Jesus taught. Here's a
typical boat out on the Sea of Galilee.
The little towns around. Nothing much
has changed. This is a boat that they
found after a tremendous drought. And
apparently, it's a boat exactly like the
ones that were used in the time of
Jesus. So, this type of boat was what
Jesus would have been in with Peter and
his disciples when he taught the great
lessons. Take your Bibles again and read
the words of Jesus, saying to yourself,
"This is God speaking to me." There is
power in that word. Here is the tomb of
Lazarus. This is where Lazarus lay. It's
a very dark tomb. Of course, it's a holy
site today. But imagine that here Jesus
called a man still in in cloths out of a
tomb, proving that he is the
resurrection and the life. And he did
this just shortly before going to
Jerusalem on the final act of his life's
work. And as he approached Jerusalem,
you can imagine what went through his
mind. This is the city of Jerusalem. And
the various gates of the ancient city
are still there. As you come down this
hill, they have built over here the
little chapel of the tears. It's built
like a teardrop. And if you go inside
the chapel of the tears, it's has this
little light on the top. And there's
this picture of the hen with the
depiction of the mother hen gathering
her chicks because Jesus said,
"Jerusalem, Jerusalem, how often I
wanted to gather you like a mother hen
her chicks, but you would not." The
famous words of Jesus.
Jerusalem, Jerusalem, thou that klest
the prophets and stonest them which are
sent unto thee. How often would I have
gathered thy children together, even as
a hen gathers her chickens under her
wings, and you would not. Nothing has
changed. The world is still exactly the
same. And on the site where the temple
stood today, there stands the Dome of
the Rock.
It's interesting here some of the
architecture. So this over here is the
gate to Damascus.
Now the archaeologists would have us
believe that the wall is not today where
it stood in ancient times. This is very
significant because Roman Catholicism
has its uh it has it inside the walls
the golutar and the Bible says Jesus was
crucified where
outside the walls. Now that's very
significant. Where was Jesus then
crucified? in the Catholic Golgatar or
in another Golgatar outside of the city.
Now, here's the present gate at the top
and what happened was here was a a pipe
burst and the Jews had to dig down to uh
stop the pipe burst and they came across
as they dug down this gate which is the
Damascus gate and you can see it's right
down opposite the present gate. So,
obviously the wall must have been in the
same place, right?
So that's very interesting. The wall was
in the same place. As you go into this
place, this is the Damascus gate. And
these must be the actual stones where
Jesus walked and where Paul walked. So
if you walk there, you're actually
walking on the same spot where Jesus
walked. Here are the Hula gates. These
are fascinating gates. The two southern
gates known as the Hula gates. They
didn't ex exist uh anymore basically
until recent times. They were built in
the second temple period. That's from
the first century. I hate this. B C E
before common era to the first century
CE common era. Thank you. We'll make
that before Christ and Anodominy.
Uh the gates provided access to the
tunnels which led up to the temple
enclosure and the ha gates were used
quite often by Jesus. They're still
closed today. There they are. Part of
the the walls and the new construction.
So Jesus must have walked up these steps
as well. There's an interesting man.
That was such a nice picture. He had his
donkey over here, this man. And I
thought, that's a nice picture. So I
took it and walked on. Biggest mistake
you can make. This little man jumped on
my back, shook me like a rag to see if
anything would fall out of my pockets.
So eventually I rewarded him for his
effort.
And then my friend came running down and
saw him and thought, "What a great
photograph." And I stood there and
giggled while he took the photograph and
did the same as I did. And the next
thing, this man was pounding him on the
back and shaking him like a rag. And he
asked me, "Why didn't you tell me?" I
said, "No, I wanted to see the show. Why
should I tell you?"
That's what they sell there in the
streets of Jerusalem. That's a carob
vendor. He's got this big jar on the
back with carrot juice. And he leans
over and you can take one of these cups
and drink from them. And this is the
Jewish sector.
Very different. An old grindstone over
there. Shops, little Jewish children. Uh
lots of strife in that country. This is
the old city of David. This is where
they soared Isaiah in two. Can you
imagine sawing someone alive into two?
and uh pretty
cruel they were. This is the the church
or the construction that is built above
what was the upper room so they say. And
this here is Gethsemane. Now if you go
to Gethsemane, you have to choose which
one. There are two. This one over here
is the Orthodox Gethsemane. They've
built this huge Orthodox church over it.
And right next to it, just a little way
away, there is the Catholic Gethsemane.
outside of which are these huge olive
trees. And they say that these are the
descendants of the olive trees that were
in the olive uh on the Mount of Olives
where Jesus went to pray.
Remember that Jesus there said, "My soul
is exceedingly sorrowful even to death.
Wait here and watch with me." Matthew
26:38.
Father, if you are willing, remove this
cup from me. Yet not my will, but yours
be done. And an angel appeared to him
from heaven, strengthening him, and
being in agony, he prayed more
earnestly, and his sweat was, as it
were, great drops of blood falling down
to the ground. Luke 43:44.
There's a lot of criticism today about
how for example uh the movie on the
passion of the Christ which is not a
very nice name for me but nevertheless
depicts the suffering of Jesus as not
being biblical. In fact it's probably
not uh enough suffering that they depict
it. I haven't seen it myself, but I've
read enough about it. And I can tell you
that Jesus suffered tremendously. And
the biblical story is very scattered.
And you have to pick it up piece by
piece. And you have to look into the
history to see what probably happened to
him. What happened here to Jesus in the
garden
was that he hadn't such anxiety that the
blood vessels in his skin burst. Now
that's a medical condition that occurs
sometimes today and it is very very very
seldom that someone survives that
condition. The stress and the trauma is
so great when the blood vessels burst
from anxiety and that uh these people
die. So what must have happened here is
exactly the same thing. And Jesus could
have died right here. But an angel
appeared from heaven and strengthened
him for what lay ahead. The Bible tells
us that that night that the disciples
forsook him and fled. Mark 14:15.
Everyone forsook him. This is the Roman
Catholic Gethsemane.
And there is again the famous rock where
they say where he prayed and where the
drops of blood fell. Now you must also
remember that paganism is rock crazy.
They have famous sites, famous caves,
famous rocks and rocks formed a very
important part in paganism. But then
again in the in the Bible stories the
patriarchs also made altars from rocks
but they didn't worship the rocks. They
worshiped God and used them as an altar
to sacrifice to God which was a type of
the sacrifice of Jesus. So it's a
totally different story. So here is a
holy rock. Apparently, that's where they
took Jesus captive. And these must be
the very steps that they led him up
because these go up to Caiaphas's
uh
temple if you like, not his temple, his
palace. And he has a depiction on the
side of them. How Jesus was led up the
steps. Whether he was taken by ropes,
the Bible does not say. Today this Roman
Catholic Church has been built over the
site and this is probably a very correct
archaeological site. And here was the
seat of the high priest who that year
was Caiaphas. Now there's some confusion
there in the Bible because when they
brought Jesus they took him to Anus. Now
Anus was the father-in-law of Caiaphas
and he was the previous high priest. And
so because the high priesthood sort of
ran in the family of course the high
priest of the previous year the older
one was still honored as a high priest
although he wasn't the acting high
priest. So the Bible is often criticized
for its description but its description
is spoton.
And also some of the criticism says that
nobody like Kaiapas ever existed. Well,
they actually found his very sarcophagus
with the name Caiaphas, high priest on
it. So that is historic as well. So if
we look at the trials of Jesus, the
Bible actually mentions seven trials of
Jesus, which is fascinating because the
number seven is the number of God. And
you will not pick this up by a casual
reading of the gospels. You have to read
all four the gospels and you have to
piece it together very very carefully
because not all of them mention all the
trials of Jesus. Some will concentrate
on Pilate. Another gospel will
concentrate on the trial of Herod. Jesus
was first taken to Anus first to Anus.
And there he had a trial before Anus.
And that is where the servant of Anna
struck Jesus in the face because Kaiapas
warned him about what he was doing or
questioned him about what he was doing.
And Jesus said, "I have done nothing in
secret. Ask these what I have said
because I have always preached in the
synagogues." And the the servant of Anna
struck him in the face. So that was the
first trial of Jesus. Then they took him
with Anus to the officiating high priest
that year who was Caiaphas. So Anus and
Caiaphas must have had another
altercation with Jesus, a trial. From
there they went to the night trial. So
they had a trial at night and the Bible
tells us that Jesus was lowered into a
pit uh prophetically in the book of
Psalms. And then they had a morning
trial because according to their law it
was illegal to have a trial by night.
You had to have it when the sun came up.
So there was a trial with Anus. There
was a trial with Caiaphas and Anus.
There was the night trial with part of
the Sanhedrin. They gathered the whole
Sanhedrin together. They had a morning
trial. And they found Jesus guilty. And
then they took him to Pilate. And Pilate
tried him. But Pilate didn't want to
decide by himself. So he sent him to
Herod. And Herod had a trial and didn't
want to do this either by himself. Sent
him back to Pilate. And there was a
final trial when he was handed over to
the Jews for crucifixion. Seven trials
in all. So this is the first place where
he was today. Of course, this is a
famous site where Peter again is
honored.
and Mary uh the picture of a goddess and
on the way to the cry blessed sacrament
chapel courtyard of holy stairs sacred
pit dungeon taken down. This is where
the prisoners were kept when there was a
night trial and here are holes in the
rock. So what normally happened is the
arms were put through over here. So the
hands went through there, up there, and
the other one through there, and then
they tied them up there, and there you
hung with your front to the facing the
front. Now, if the Jews found someone
guilty, they had the right to inflict a
punishment, but capital punishment under
Roman law, they were not allowed to
inflict. They had to get permission from
the Romans. So that was a Roman law. But
they were allowed to inflict punishment.
If they found someone guilty, they were
allowed to give 13 lashes on one side
and 13 lashes on the other in the front.
So they found Jesus guilty. The Bible
doesn't report it, but it's possible
that they gave him the 26 lashes on the
front. That's possible,
although the Bible does not say so. And
here is a pit where they would lower a
person down and they would be lowered
down naked. And here's some Bzantium
crosses that are on the wall over here
showing that the early Christians
recognized this as a sight. You would
come down this hole. In other words, you
were lowered down and then you were in
this dungeon in total darkness. And
Psalm says they have lowered me into the
pit. So this is what must have happened
to Jesus as he waited there throughout
the night for the morning trial to be
convened
today. You can go into the pit over
there and you can have a look of it.
Then from there after the morning trial
he was taken to Pilate where he was put
into this prison while he awaited trial.
That's what it looks like down there.
And then he was found
uh
innocent by Pilate. Pilate did not want
to sentence him to death. So he sent him
to Herod. They mocked him. They gave him
the his cloak. The Bible says that they
they tore out his beard. They hit him in
the face, told him to prophesy who was
hitting them. He was very maltreated in
that occasion. And this is lit stratus
where Pilate eventually sentenced him.
He has still Roman games on the floor
over there. And this is where Pilate
said the famous words, "Echo homo,
behold the man." And he was there with a
crown of thorns on his head. He had been
beaten. In fact, Pilate, the Bible says,
and his first trial with Pilate had him
beaten to gain the sympathy of the Jews.
That's a pretty cowardly thing to do.
Now, Roman lashings consisted of 40
lashes minus one. So, they were tied
around the pillar and then they were
lashed with 40 lashes minus one. And the
lash that they used had a number of
strains and it had pieces of stone or
metal on the front. In fact, many of the
people who were sentenced to those
lashes died from the lashes. just from
the lashes because the lashes would curl
down and rip open the skin and rip open
the flesh. And records tell us that
people that were beaten with those
lashes, their endrails sometimes hung
out just from those lashings. So that
was a tremendous punishment. And then of
course another possibility is that he
was lashed twice because when he was
found guilty in the end and sentenced to
crucifixion then you could be then you
were lashed before crucifixion. The
Bible doesn't say whether he was lashed
both the times but it's possible
possible that it could have happened.
Now they also claimed that Pilate didn't
exist. Well, here's an actual
inscription that was found, the Pontius
Pilus inscription, which categorically
states that he was the procurator in the
time of Tiberius. So, biblically,
archaeologically, there is no way that
the biblical story can be denied. So,
some depict the lashing in this way.
Others depict that the lashing took
place being bent over a horizontal
pillar and lashed in that way.
The Bible also says that when they put
the crown of thorns upon him and they
gave him a staff in his hand that they
took the staff and they hit him over the
head with it. But the Greek used there
depicts that they hit him over the head
again and again and again. So the
sufferings of Jesus were enormous. The
Bible actually depicts that he was
wounded and that the wound was one big
wound. That he was one big wound from
the top to the bottom. So Jesus suffered
like no other man has suffered for
anybody or any criminal act ever in the
history of mankind. And if God hadn't
sent an angel to strengthen him, he
would not even have made it. And that is
why when he hung on that cross, he still
forgave those who did it to him. And why
he died so quickly while the others who
hung there longer had to have their legs
broken because that was a way to ensure
that they stayed on the cross and didn't
get off. See, if they were hung on a on
a on a Sabbath on a Friday
and they didn't die on that Friday, then
they broke the legs because otherwise on
the Sabbath they could climb down from
the cross and that would be a disaster
because nobody could catch them because
it was the Sabbath. So, better break
their legs. Terrible stories in those
old days. And then he was, the Bible
says, led to Golgota. Now this is the
famous street the via de la roa where he
must have walked and according to the
Bible he was led outside the city. That
means he must have come down this road
and gone outside that gate which used to
be the sheep's gate and he must have
gone out there. That would make sense.
The sheep's gate is where the sacrifices
were taken to be burnt outside the city.
If you are of Catholic mind, then you
must have come up these stairs to go to
the inner Golgata. I'll take you to both
and I'll show you both of them. And the
Bible says that he carried his cross,
but that he collapsed under it and that
uh he had to be helped. Somebody had to
take over for him. This is the famous
Via de la Roa.
As you go up, we were actually traveling
here, walking here through a tunnel
which is known as Hezekiah's tunnel
where we had a bad experience with
stoning.
And here is the famous Catholic u
seleure or the famous church where they
claim Golgatar was. Now fortunately for
Roman Catholicism, everything fits into
this one church. the place where the
cross stood plus the place where the
grave is all in one church. Very
convenient for pilgrims.
Uh on the one side over here they have
this plaque. You have the pomegranates
and the grapes. The pomegranates and the
grapes exactly like you would have in
the temples of Baal. Exactly the same.
So interesting little pagan anomalies in
this place. When you come into this
Catholic Golgata, you have the various
urns hanging there with the holy salts.
You have the famous stones. Again,
here's a man just kissing this slab.
This slab over here
is the one where they apparently laid
the body after it came down from the
cross. And here is the famous sephila
where you go in. This is where he was
buried, so they say. So, this is a holy
site. If you go in there and you pay the
priest and he blesses you, you have
absolution for a number of months.
H that's inside. Very tiny little place.
And the Bible says there was a huge
stone rolled in front of the place.
Here's a tiny little place in a church
which they say is the seplic. That's
what it's like. You can just turn
around. You can get an idea of the size
if you look at the the candles there.
They're pretty small. And that's it.
That's all that you can move around. If
you go up the stairs in the church, then
you come to a place where people are
very reverent. And that is where Golgata
was. They have all these statues of
Jesus and the Mary and the women around
and uh very much gold and silver and
glitter. And there is the spot right
over there where the cross stood. Now
there's a Orthodox Golgata which is not
too far away from there and you can in
the same church apparently and you can
put your money there or you could put
your money here. You can choose. And if
you go into that spot then you have a
special blessing. That's something you
wouldn't want to miss. So my friend and
I went in there to see what there was.
And then here is a rock which they say
is the skull of Golgata just there in
the church. and they say that's the
skull. So that's the famous Roman
Catholic Golgatar which has most of the
pilgrims in the world. If you come out
of the sheep's gate which today is the
lion's gate. In the old days it was the
sheep's gate. If you go outside and you
remember that the wall is actually
probably where it stood in the old days
from the archaeology,
then you have a problem if you are in
the Catholic Golgata because then you're
inside the city. The Bible says he was
crucified outside the city. Salvation is
for everyone. It is not only for the
select few within the city. And so when
you come out, you see this huge rock
over here that still today has the face
of a skull on it over there as you see.
And on top today there's a Muslim uh
burial site. Uh it's called the place of
the skull. In actual fact, what it was
was a quarry. Fascinating. So this was a
quarry where um Solomon had the stones
dug that were for the temple.
Fascinating. So in actual fact, this
whole valley and it's part of a mountain
that continued up from left to right and
actually formed the mount on which the
temple stood.
And it's interesting that this is the
place where Abraham
probably simulated in type the death of
the son of God through the sacrifice of
Isaac. But God said, "You do not have to
provide your son, I will provide mine."
And uh so it's actually the same hill.
Fascinating. So this would this would
make sense that Jesus died on top of
that hill. God is love. God so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever
believeth in him should not perish but
have everlasting life. John 3:16.
Outside very close just at the base of
that hill is the garden tomb.
And then they took the body of Jesus and
wound it in linen clothed with spices as
the manner of the Jews is to bury. Now
in the place where he was crucified,
there was a garden and the garden a new
sephila wherein was never a man yet
laid. That's what the Bible says. So
totally unlike the one inside the city,
here is a garden outside. Today is still
a beautiful garden. Now a garden in the
Bible actually means a farm. This was a
vineyard. And here's still an old wine
press. So, this makes sense. There's an
old wine press and a beautiful little
garden today, the wine press from the
side. And there, after a dig for
excavating for buildings, they found
this site. And lo and behold, here were
some tombs. And in front of the tomb, if
you can see over there, is a little
wall. And in that wall which acted as a
furrow, they put a big round stone that
could have rolled in front of that tomb.
And if you look down, you will have to
look into the tomb and look across and
there is a tomb that has been heuned out
a little bit. So this was not finished
yet. The Bible says it was not a
finished tomb. No one had laid there
yet. And the Bible also says that the
disciples bent down to see what was
inside. So they could have looked in
through here past that pillow and they
would have seen that tomb over there and
they would have known that it is empty.
So this fits the biblical description
perfectly.
Also in that garden you have this herb
that grows over there from which they
make a drug that could anthetize and
that's the one that they mixed with wine
and aniththetized anyone who was uh on
the cross but Jesus rejected to drink
that. This is a Methodist uh pastor who
runs that place. There's a typical
stone. This is the grave of Herod. one
of the few intact graves of that type
today, showing that that's probably what
it was like. So, here is the probable
sight of the garden tomb. There is the
little furrow and in front of it would
have been this big round stone that
would have had to be rolled away. That
makes far more sense to me than the
other Golgatar. Inside it looks like
that. Of course, people believe it's a
holy site. So they come here to uh pray
and be reverent which is fine but on it
says he's not here he's risen and that
to me is the crux of the matter he's not
here he's risen my God I do not have to
go and seek him in some holy place or in
some dig risen I can talk to him right
here I can talk to him wherever I am
because he can hear him because He is
the resurrection and the life. And he
that believes in me, though he were
dead, yet shall he live. John 11:25.
For it is by grace that you have been
saved through faith. Ephesians 2:8.
You know, a religion based on form and
formality is so empty once you have
experienced Jesus Christ. Here's the
Mount of Olives, the chapel of the
ascension.
Tiny little chapel. And uh that's
apparently the place where Jesus went up
into heaven. And this over here is the
famous golden gate.
It's bricked up and it's closed up. And
on the other side there's a stairway
leading up to the temple mount where
today there's the Dome of the Rock. And
here lie the graves of the richest of
the rich of the Muslim world. And they
believe that when Jesus returns, he will
come here and the golden gate will open
up. Not Jesus to them, to them the
Immani, the Messiah. To the Jews, the
Messiah, to the Christians, the return
of Jesus. This gate will open up. And
because they happen to be lying over
there, because they had lots of money to
purchase that particular grave, they
will be resurrected first and they will
be the first to enter into that place.
How nice and convenient. Do you think
it'll work like that? I doubt it because
if they had studied the biatitudes,
they would have known what it takes to
see Jesus. We have to feel sorrow for
our sins.
We have to repent. We have to mourn and
we have to ask Jesus to change us and we
have to come back into harmony with him
and his principles. And then we don't
need that gate. We have another gate.
It's a gate that has pearls on it and it
is a heavenly Jerusalem that was built
by God. I don't know whether there will
be much of a resurrection in the first
resurrection here. I don't want to judge
that. That is for God to judge. But here
they are all waiting for an earthly
kingdom. I'm not waiting for an earthly
kingdom. I'm waiting for a heavenly
Jerusalem. As exciting as this one might
be. Is this the Dome of the Rock? Is
this the place where a temple will
stand? If you go inside of this one,
there's a stone again. That's where
Muhammad went up. But paganism and truth
are very far from each other. This is
Jerusalem by night and this is the
famous burnt house. That's all that's
left of it. In 70 AD, the Romans came
and they destroyed Jerusalem and it
burnt down to the ground. And that is a
type of the destruction of the world
that is coming when God returns. We can
either become part of burnt house or we
can become part of the kingdom of God.
That is our choice. And the only
solution to that is he that has the son
has life and he that has not the son of
God has not life. These things I have
written unto you. Believe on the name of
the son of God that you know that you
have eternal life. 1 John 5:12.
So that is our choice today. We can
either be hung up in all the things of
this world and we can make holy places
more important than God or we can
develop a relationship.
But the price is self. We'll have to
give it up and ask God to give us his
character. A character that can
understand, get along, and love our
neighbor as we love ourselves. And to
let God supreme in our lives. Because
without him we can do nothing. Amen.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Oh,
come on.
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh.
Oh my go
oh oh
Come on.